Hello
and welcome to the Active Inference Lab.
Today it is October 25th, 2021,
and we are here in Active
Inference Guest stream number 12.1
with Martin Butz.
So this is going to be an awesome
presentation and discussion
if you're watching live.
Please feel free to add
any questions into the live chat
and we'll be compiling those
and otherwise
we're just going to have a presentation
and then discussion interval.
So, Martin, thanks so much for joining
our lab to give this presentation.
And we're really looking forward
to what you have to share.
Yeah, a big pleasure to be here tonight,
this morning, I guess, for you guys
in California.
So let's see if I get the.
Screen sharing here. Right.
Again, we practiced before this.
This one here
looks great.
And I just need.
To have at least one video on the side
here for me.
So, yeah, big pleasure
to present our labs
work on which I call event predictive,
active inference, and particularly
also modeling the development
of conceptual compositional cognition
from sensorimotor experiences.
You might have already
kind of noticed the picture here.
This artistic picture on the top, right?
And I think it shows nicely
and intuitively
how our brain continuously
seems to attempt
to infer the hidden causes
behind our sensory perceptions.
And thus this kind of terrace,
this kind of bend for us a little bit.
Because the top part, of course.
Just can be.
Interpreted in two ways in this,
obviously
not quite rightly positioned
or it cannot be like this.
In reality,
it gives you a couple of other examples.
What I mean by this active inference,
which is known to
or explained often by friston and others,
to accentuate, essentially develop
latent hidden states to explain
away. The.
Sensory sections by inferring
the hidden causes behind them.
So here you see in color illustration,
which is the cortical illusion sometimes.
Where you. Probably won't believe it.
I have to measure it each time again
to make sure that I'm really right.
But essentially in this yellow
tinted figure, essentially
these blue colored squares here,
they are essentially grayscale. Now.
If you test them by.
A. New graphics program, you will see
that this is a grayscale position.
So I blue points here.
In fact, grayscale.
And here on this side
with the blue tinted background,
you essentially have the same situation.
But it's the yellow pieces. That are.
Actually grayscale as illustrated
here on the right little bit.
And this just shows essentially
that our brain.
Is. Interpreting its sensory perceptions
in the light more and logically fitting.
Here.
Of the circumstances.
Now, in this case, yellow light
makes a true blue square appear gray
when we look at it.
So we perceive it gray.
The sensory stimulation is gray,
but the true cause behind
it must be a blue square.
So i i brain essentially correctly
and actively infers that this squares
most likely blue, because under this
yellow light conditions it appears gray.
And we're not even aware of that.
So this is.
Roughly an.
Example of a very low level
inference process in our brain
that takes into account the situation
and essentially puts
the perceptual sensory
information in this event,
this light event,
this lightning condition, essentially.
Another.
Nice example of this is these shadows
that I found here on line
from from some artistic exhibition.
And you have here two shadows.
And as long as you look at the shadows
and you perceive the shadows, you kind of
not only perceive the shadows,
but you perceive a person
and the illustration of a person
and to a certain extent,
you have the feeling that some person
must be standing here
somewhere, such that.
I. Will perceive this, this shadows.
But lo and behold.
This situation is totally different.
These are actually cool artistic
sculptures that produce the shadows.
And again, you see that they are
you have perceived
the shadow and interpreted
not only the shadow, but created
a whole scene, the whole event like this
and a light source
and the person in the middle.
And then the.
Shadow that produces this in order
to make sense of the shadow itself.
Yeah.
So again, you inferred the hidden causes
behind the shadow in this case.
Not quite correctly.
Because it's a cool
illustrating, a cool artistic
sculpture here that's
with an installation with a light source.
Perfectly positioned, such
that the sculpture creates
a particular human like shadow figure.
So the first proposition. That I.
Take out of
this is essentially that our brain
seems to be this generative predictive
model and uses active inference
essentially with this generative
predictive model to generate acting,
inferring internal activities
that is internal, active and coatings
that try to explain away
the current sensory perceptions
and thus make sense of it in the sense
that we explain them away
by ideally inferring the true
hidden causes.
Behind.
The perceptions
that we actually perceive.
This generative predictive models
explains a way perceptions
it maintains distributed
predictive activities
which form this kind of attractors,
which often then are formalized,
particularly by Friston.
And his. Followers.
So to say.
And in. Various ways.
Formalizing this and.
Essentially suggesting
that the brain develops
this local free energy minima,
this local attractor like minima,
that is the consistent explanation
of a particular perception
that you currently
have under consideration.
So this would be, for example,
in the shadow situation, right?
We perceive the shadow, but we know
intuitively that
there's a light source and something
in between that produces a shadow.
And thus in the.
In the shadow of a person,
we essentially immediately
have the feeling
that some person must be standing there.
The free energy formalism essentially
pushes towards the generation
of these generative predictive models
and pushes towards
the continuous active inference processes
that are unfolding
within these developing generative
predictive models
and one can nicely distinguish
three kind of aspects
of this general inference
process formalism.
And that is on the one.
Hand site on the first insight,
knowing what is going on.
So that's essentially the fast adaptation
of internal model activities
towards this local free energy minima
to explain to ourselves what's going on.
So if you looked altogether at the shadow
and you perceive the shadow, then
you perceive not only
the shadow, but you had the feeling
that you inferred the causes.
That is, that there is a person in
the light source that creates the shadow.
Now then the second part is learning
more about the world.
We can revise our generative
predictive models.
For example, you have now revised your
predictive models learning about that.
There are some cool people
that make sculptures that produce human
like shadows, and there's
no human actually, but just a sculpture.
And so you have learn something
new about the world essentially.
And we draw the first two aspects
of inference
aspects essentially, of course,
only to really survive in our world,
to live, to interact
with our world in better manners.
So to really pursue our goals.
And our knowledge driven behavior.
Of epistemic behavior
with them by the means of these
developing generative predictive models.
Let me explain it a little bit further.
So so it's clear how I mean, this
so essentially
also implied by the generative
by the free energy
formalism and extra inference formalism,
one can say
that our brain is continuously.
On the one. Hand side.
In the. Present for sure. Right.
I mean, we are ready.
Why we for example, write a letter here.
We are ready to produce the
next word and write it out
on paper.
For example, we consider the recent past
by doing this
to be really in the present
and fully embodied and grounded in the.
Here and now.
The present
is also continuously updated
by our sensory
feedback, by interact with environment.
So for example,
we might update our belief how sturdy
the pencil is or how hot it is
and things like this.
And we.
Learn about our.
World while we interact with it, such
as improving our writing skills
and so forth.
But most importantly, we use this
presentation of the presence
and the belief where.
We are in. Essentially to.
Predict. The future.
What is going to happen,
if you like, this future considerations.
And then.
Essentially to pursue particular future
desired situation such as finalizing
writing this letter, writing this word,
producing a letter for another person.
And. Having overall purposes.
Also other purposes, of course,
for the current day and so forth.
And these considerations,
depending on our focus
and the difference
between the desired future considerations
and the current expected future
considerations
make us improve our behavior and act in
Nicole directed manner its environment.
One can.
Illustrate this in a different way
by essentially.
Saying, Well, the.
Active inference
framework essentially suggests
that we are continuous in a predictive
state of mind, ready
to produce, to process
the next sensory information
for doing information integration.
They're producing local posteriors,
integrating this local posteriors
as perception with our overall beliefs
and our models, or perceiving the shadow
inferring that there's
probably a personal light source
that produces the shadow integrating
and overall consistent in attempting
to create an overall consistent,
a posterior predictive state of mind.
And we use this state
of mind essentially. To.
Roll out future considerations,
including habitually behavior
with our environment test.
If you like this,
if you want to go there,
or if you want to pursue particular,
other,
other, other states in the future, choose
the best one we can do.
Execute it, and then close the loop
by using the reference
copy to do the temporal prediction
in the here and now.
This epistemic goal
directed behavior
can essentially be formalized nicely.
In this.
Reasonably short creation style.
Tool.
To generate
golder active epistemic behavior.
This comes from Friston and Zullo
at its work in 2015,
which essentially
I think is a very nicely formalized,
intuitive equation here, actually.
So let's be pursuing the minimization
of free energy under a particular policy
pie at a certain state, and pursuing this
free energy consists of two components.
The first component is essentially
the pursuer.
The goal directed component.
And in this equation, it's essentially
trying to minimize the difference
between the observations
that are expected to perceive.
When I pursue a particular policy pie
and so a particular behavior pie.
And compared to the observations
that I would like to perceive
under my internal model,
so this is essentially the expected
divergence from desired future states.
And I pursue I try to then of course
infer a policy pies or behavior pie
that minimizes
the divergence from the expected
future states to the desired future
states.
The other component in this
equation is the epistemic
part.
It's essentially
the minimization to attempt
to minimize expected future uncertainty.
So it's the expectation of over my future
horizon tower.
This for my.
Timeline into the future
as you see here and it's essentially the
the expectation of future uncertainty,
which I try to minimize as well.
So under my consideration
of my policy pie,
I expect future internal states and Towle
and this entails under the policy
lead to the expectation
of future observations and then certainty
of this observation.
So the observation density is essentially
so the entropy over. That, the more.
Uncertain the the, the more diffuse
my expectation, the more uncertain
my expectation, the less
I like this future considerations.
And out of this two components
in the equation, one can essentially
derive agents that act
in directed and epistemic manners.
We have done
implemented such agents.
Mainly.
Partially.
As. Rather still rather crude
approximations, simply
with recurrent neural network structures.
Here, for example, this rocket ball agent
that was is controlled by a newer
network on the fly, essentially by first
training the network to learn the.
Sensorimotor model. Of this agent.
So this agent.
Undergoes.
Gravity and has inertia,
and the simulation in 2D
and has this to a thrust
that go diagonally
diagonally downwards so it can contract
gravity and steer,
as you see essentially.
And the red line that you see here
is essentially the imagination
of the neural network where it expects
to fly to over the next couple of steps.
So essentially the system rolls out, as
I illustrated
before, essentially into the future.
It's sensorimotor dynamics that expected
sensorimotor dynamics under expected
motor control commands
that it imagines executing.
And it then compares this.
The resulting stage
with the desired state
can take the divergence
or simply the delta if it's to domestic.
And you
said delta to
projected back onto the motor commands.
So that's the system essentially acts
in its own best interest
to pursue this goals.
The goals are given from the outside
in this case.
So this is still a rather simple system
in the sense that it's not probabilistic
really, or tries to minimize
uncertainty here,
but just for some goal directed behavior.
We have also done this
with various other systems.
For example, the multi. Joined
arm that.
Additionally has to constrain
to avoid collisions
which are signaled by this here
sensors as you see here.
And you can also get quite some good
behavior, very similar principle.
And so to conclude the first part
right now,
I hope you have understood
the active inference component. And.
Inferences about essentially
also suggesting implicitly
that our mind is not only about knowing
what is going on, it also continuously
learns about the words retrospectively.
So it's partially also in the past,
in some sense in its activities state
and in the future.
Considering and.
Inferring or directed epistemic behavior.
However,
this is certainly good
and we can generate
closed loop
control systems in this manner
which are closely related to model
predictive control, for that matter.
But in.
Order to really become event
predictive or.
More.
Abstract in our scene, right, right
now, essentially you have seen a system
that only is just writing something
or is controlling a flying trajectory.
Right.
It's not really able to decide
to write a whole letter.
Right, in the sense right.
F Strictly speaking,
so it's not able to abstract the way
from the actual current behavior.
So the question is how
where do this event,
predictive structures
that I was talking about come in?
And that leads me
to my second proposition.
That's essentially that
that it appears to be
that due to evolutionary shaped
inductive processing biases,
our brain develops
even predictive compositional structures.
These structures
tend to model the hidden causes
behind sensory perceptions,
if already intuitively seen it.
I want to illustrate this further
with an actual motor behavior,
but before I do so, let me characterize
where this
where this proposition
essentially comes from, right
where where does this belief, that event
predictive structures are the right way
to go, the right way to abstract forward.
And it comes from
from the psychological literature mainly.
And I start with the quotation
here from Jeff Sex and Barbara
Fescue from 2001,
which essentially reads, okay, event
events have been characterized
as a segment of time
at a given location that is conceived
by an observer to have a.
Beginning and an end and their.
Behavior up psychological
work essentially is suggested
that when you have people
segment movies or other little scenes
or cartoons, even in things like this,
they do this very systematically.
So they have a really clear perception
when.
An event starts and when it ends.
And out of this,
it's appears
that we process our environment
in terms of we perceive our environment
in terms of these events.
But the important is that the event is
it's not really in the environment
per say, right? There's no labor.
This is an event.
But our brain constructs these events
and that's what what they're.
Baldwin lovely put into a recent
special issue contribution so she says.
Baldwin Cosi
should they say events the experiences
we think we are having and recall having
had they are constructed.
They are not what actually occurs
because what occurs in the end
is ongoing, dynamic, marginal
and multidimensional sensory flow,
which is somewhat transformed via
psychological processes
into structure, describable,
memory, evidence of experience now.
And so essentially, right,
there is no labor of events,
but our brain creates this abstractions
and this compact
and encoding of the events
that we perceive. Of.
That exists in our environment.
But we construct them essentially.
They are not really existing.
On their own.
And over last years, a lot of research
has focused on this event
predictive cognition.
And this research
essentially investigates
how events and cocktails,
conceptualizations, that of
I learned structured
and processed dynamically.
And this research line
essentially suggests that event
predictive in coatings and processes
optimally mediate between sensorimotor
processes and language.
Maybe I should have put inference
processes here.
So this is a quote
from our recent special issue.
So in summary, this event, predictive
cognition essentially comes from
psychological research.
To. Ask is work is to have sex
and to have sex continuation until today.
Actually, there's much more recent work
from him about this.
It's rooted partially even more deeply
in behavioral psychology.
If you look at the common
coding theory of
welcome trends and switch or behavior
control theory of your outcome,
Hoffman and Bennett Thomas
work on the theory of event coding.
If you want to learn more about this,
I'll allow me
to point you to our recent special issue
on this topic.
In the topics
in Cognitive Science Journal.
With quite a variety of contributions
spanning developmental neuro
and behavioral psychology,
also linguistics
contributions.
And cognitive modeling and.
Computational contributions.
So what are these event structures
now really about?
It's essentially
when we think about particular event
predictive structures, right?
One can quickly.
Go to the conclusion while events
must be somewhat distributed, networks
that essentially predict
the types of entities
that are involved in an event
like a class and the hand and an agent
that reaches for the glass to drink,
drink out of it.
The relative spatial relations
between the hand and object, for example,
and the interaction dynamics such as
the hand would be moving to that object.
These are event structures
and then we have somehow this feeling of
event boundaries and event transitions.
We know when a particular event can
commence and when it can enter
and can begin and end.
And so, for example,
when I grasp this cup
here, I just can basically grasp it.
And once I have grasp it, I can transport
it and then I can put it back down.
And I'm. Free again.
So to say,
combined with events and event boundaries
I create, I can create mentally
event schemas which have previously
and previously shows
are called scripts and similar things.
And I think these scripts and develop
naturally out of this event predictive
coding principle
and this event predictive coding
principle, we essentially have now a much
more clearer idea, I think, of what
these scripts and schematics
have often been characterized before.
Actually are.
And of course, once we have schemata,
we can embed them again and other events
forming hierarchies out of that.
So to get back to this illustration
of writing a letter,
we can now say essentially, well,
we our mind is
not really in a continuous past
consideration,
but it considers past events essentially
or the unfolding of past events.
And notice
that these do not need to be partitioned
as Chris visits illustrated here.
And we have certainly events
unfolding in parallel.
For example,
if you think about the letter
writing here
at your writing, for example,
the second word here is a scholar or so,
but you also have the full writing
this letter event
in your head, this event of having
sit down at the table
and being ready to write this letter.
So there multiple event aspects,
of course, that consider
particular subcomponents of the lecture
through environment out there.
And so again, we know what's going on.
We can retrospectively.
Improve.
Our individual writing skills
for writing particular words,
for writing in general,
but also our excuse
of writing a whole letter
and improving this, for example.
And then we can again pursue the events
of finalizing this letter,
posting it later on and so forth.
So we have a full sequence in mind
that actually.
Then.
Includes the concludes,
the full letter writing episode
that is not only in the letter
but also putting a stamp on the
envelope,
putting the letter in the envelope,
putting it to the post office
and so forth.
So all this is included
for the fun of it.
I included this lovely video
project here.
So here we see an event of a.
Of a.
Billiard ball or pool table
starting situation and somebody.
Is shooting the white boy.
And, and so.
We have a nice sit and we look,
oh, some balls hit the ball.
It's a hole.
No, no, they don't actually.
Low and behold, they come back together
to the starting position.
So I hope
the video was a nice illustration of you
definitely having expected something
totally different, although not
something very concrete,
but at least the final state of the event
that the balls will be distributed around
the table in some form or the other.
Certainly they will not ever come back
to the starting position like this.
And that's why hopefully. Some of you.
Were at least
a little smiling to themselves.
Yeah, that it's
kind of a cool illustration now.
That my brain.
Has this events in mind
and it essentially steps, jumps
ahead, right
when the starting of an event unfolds,
it kind of knows what the final situation
is most likely going to be,
even if it's not fully concrete.
But it still has some in the pie
situation deployed by a situation,
a distributional sense to it.
So it's also really interesting
and we have low and behold actually
formalized this event predictive active
inference now and an event effective
inference model where.
The modeled.
Reaching behavior and visual.
Eye. Fixation behavior in infants
actually together.
With.
Colleagues from from Potsdam University
from the development developmental
psychology side.
So now we essentially have the same.
Same.
Equation again as before,
but it's only conditioned now.
On. Events here as you see.
So the whole equation.
Is. Conditioned on in which events
we believe to be currently in.
So the latent hidden state,
this model we had before is now
an event model. And
and so and we put the
M basically as the in turn in motivation.
So the desired observations
given motivations are compared
with the expected observations pursuing
a particular policy under condition
that we are in the particular.
Event and and the particular event series
unfolds while.
Interacting with environment
to illustrate this further
because actually, yes, has done this work
and so provided
this following illustration here when.
We have.
Now as the behavior policy here,
for example, the case position
of saying to an infant
and so we might start somewhat
explain this equation
a little bit further by the situation
that, okay, the infant
say it's he
or she really likes teddy bears.
So basically
it's really it's internal motivation
is to look at teddy bear teddy bears.
And and.
It really perceives
a lot of pleasure out of that.
So it really likes
to look at teddy bears.
And so its observation is the desire
to see a teddy bear like objects.
And thus
by. Pursuing a policy
that minimizes divergence
from seeing teddy bears.
So essentially
it will fixate teddy bears.
But now when.
We now see that suddenly
this ball here is moving.
Now. There might be a surprise
in the observation because the baby
probably has expected that
everything else will stay rather stable.
So what is happening
is that there is a large uncertainty of
what this polar picture is suddenly doing
and where it's roiling from.
And this makes
the baby, for example,
look at the ball now
because it wants to know all its roads
and build a good predictive model.
So it's not surprised off the ball, given
it caught its attention
in the first place,
of course, and sofas
seems to be somewhat relevant for itself.
And so it actually predicts
the next ball location
and it will also continue
then to most likely
at least depending on the age, of course,
little later age
probably then illustrated in this picture
here, predict that this ball
will eventually fall to the ground
and thus it actually will
at some point anticipate
not only the next ball position,
but will look at the critical next
ball position, which would be
when does this object
then suddenly fall to the ground?
Yeah. And so.
We have kind of a two event prediction,
the immediate next situation.
And the.
Event boundary when the ball switches
from rolling into falling
and then expecting
that it will fall somewhere on the floor
and hopefully not in a teddy bear.
So to
get this really important
and lo and behold,
the study is from from Adam Moritz
it's Adam and big it it's now.
Is showing that in over.
The first year. Of.
Our human life usually we develop
this anticipatory event predictive.
I gaze behavior so what they did
so essentially they showed little kids,
little videos of hands grasping
teddy bears or little claw
like Gerber scrappers,
grasping teddy bears
or other simple kind of objects.
And what you can show is that
when you track the this baby's eyes
for six months of age, they don't show
any anticipatory gaze behavior.
So they they track the object, the hand
that moves to the target object at best.
Usually
they even like a little bit behind.
But lo and behold,
with seven and a half months of age
about.
The. The babies start to anticipate
and they do so
particularly and only
so when there is an effect, when the hand
not only reaches for that entity,
but then also lifts it.
So of course, after its test
trials are done there
in this experiment, so usually in
after the first or second try.
And the hand really.
Shakes the object a little bit.
Then the.
Babies start to anticipate
and they only do so this about 11 months
when there's no effect,
when the hand just reaches for the object
but doesn't do anything with it.
So then they stay on the reactive or hand
following behavior
and only do this later on.
On the anticipate.
In the.
Later age was about 11 months old
and interestingly with a claw
they at seven and a half
they don't anticipate at all.
So they don't see any attentiveness
or any anticipation that this crowd
will do something with the object.
But with 11 months of age,
they essentially show
the similar behavior.
Then when they watch a hand
with seven and a half months
in, the hand lifts the object,
the claw lifts object.
Then they also start to anticipate
to watch 11 months,
but only once, 18 months.
They also anticipate.
When the clock.
Is not lifting the object,
but just moving there and lo and behold,
we simulated this with our event
predictive, active inference model.
Essentially assuming.
So to say, simulating that.
The until.
About six months of age
they just don't cannot interpretive
and often hand reaching for objects
and so they just cannot make an event
case out of it.
And they just
process the unexpected information that
as the hand starts moving and they trick.
The hand.
With 12 months of age, it's
similar to when they see a claw.
But with 12 months of age,
when they see your hand and an object
they imagine are probably
this hand wants to reach for the object.
And so once the hand starts moving.
They will and they will move.
Their eyes to the object
to be ready to process
what the hand is going to do
with the object.
And in fact, the model.
This now.
Was. An event predictive vision
modeling approach
essentially that essentially implements
this active inference equation
and event predictive level
that I just showed.
So it's it's essentially essentially
first trained to learn a realistic event,
predictive schemata of the unfolding
dynamic, starting and ending conditions.
And then it.
Applies active inference of the current
best event interpretation first.
So the trust needs to know which event.
So if it sees the situation, it needs to
infer
is reaching
event is most likely to unfold.
And once it's certain
that the reaching for event unfolds
so it knows are reaching
and with a grasping and something
doing something with the object.
So I will look there to minimize
my future
expected uncertainty, minimizing
this anticipated
uncertainty of what
the hand is going to do with the object.
And maybe you can look at the.
Results in detail. In the paper.
Essentially what is happening
is that the system.
Learns.
To during training to
infer the correct events and then during
testing after sufficient training phases
rather quickly,
it starts to anticipate.
To. When the reach starts here.
Over time.
It starts to anticipate
and look at the goal object
because it has encoded.
This is a retraining event.
And I know.
How the reaching event unfolds.
And thus I look
at the end of the reaching event
because I want to minimize.
The the free energy.
That I anticipate unfolding in the near
future while reaching and grasping.
An. Object.
Because this is the situation
that I'm currently in
so that's what the system emergent
so to say that's that's
what emergent called anticipatory gaze
by this active inference or event
predictive active inference formalism.
So okay
we have shown that this thetan static,
latent and coatings
that can nicely foster
the emergence of this
anticipatory behavior.
But can such or how can such event
predictive structures actually learned?
This is what I want to show you next.
But it could also have a short break,
if you like, Daniel,
or what you say.
So maybe ask and just double down
on a few of these cool points
and ask a few questions and then jump
into the second part of the presentation.
Yeah, please. Okay.
So a few just kind of general questions.
One was
you brought in the neural network angle
and so that it was just
a general question how do the analytical
single line equation formalism
connect to different modern machine
learning architectures?
And what does that have to do
with the scaling
or where
active inference could be applied?
I think I'm going to answer this
in the second part of my talk.
Perfect.
Okay.
This is going to become much
more neural networks just now.
And I will conclude also
with a general statement about this.
So maybe we keep this for later,
essentially.
I mean, this was an LTM network.
LSM networks are used for state
of the art machine learning.
So it's not like.
Something that.
Is like totally trivial or so.
Great. And
the events
basis is
something that I'm sure you'll return to.
But you mentioned
how events have boundaries and schema
or schemata and hierarchies,
and one thought was, how are these
boundaries, schema
and hierarchies learned in humans,
and how does that inform our design
of cognitive systems? Yes.
Also, this is kind of what I continue
is essentially
this is the question here, like,
so how are these event
predictive structures learned?
Not so much in humans.
I will not so much focus on in the talk
now, but how can this be
lost in artificial systems but inspired
of course, by human learning?
Well, I'm maximally uncertain
and curious about those,
I guess implicitly expected
and prefer that they be resolved.
But I hope so.
It just reminded me
of how they're in culture, like
at the end of a movement of a symphony.
If you clap, you didn't get it.
Because that's not the uncultured moment
to clap.
There's a broader event
that actually goes beyond the sound.
And so it just made me think
about how through learning,
we reconceptualize what events are.
And if events truly are one of the
a kind of atomic units of cognition,
then that's incredibly powerful.
I would think so, yes.
Was this a question or comment?
That was just a comment
on the importance of having events
based cognitive processes
and how it reconsiders
our own experience and suggests
how to design other architectures.
So maybe we can go to the second part
of the presentation.
A fantastic part is really right
that it goes hand in hand, right?
While these events develop, we are
we getting more and more ready to look
and explore deeper event structures,
right, and more complex event structures.
And of course, the real mystery is
how this events structures are learned.
And I want to show you a couple of ideas
that we are pursuing in our mind,
the machine learning research part.
And then the last part of the talk,
I will link this event structure
also to language structures
to a certain extent.
So but allow me,
it didn't interest of time
to go a little bit fast over this machine
learning components here because to
I had to explain the machine
learning architectures
in all that detail
it would take talks on on its own.
But I just want to give you a little bit
of an idea where we are in this respect.
But the main question that was asked,
and that's also really a really good
question is essentially what are these?
How can
our brain learn this event structures?
And there must be essentially in machine
learning
jargon
all these inductive learning biases.
Yeah, these inductive tendencies to learn
this event predictive structures
and ideally
to learn them in a very compact,
very suitably compressed form, to
identify the causality
that generate
the sensory perceptions
in the first place and allow them
to combine
these event structures
in a very composition,
a very flexible manner, such
that we get ready. To.
To apply our knowledge
also in other situations that are related
to previous experiences,
but of course always different.
And. And I argued before that essentially
they must on the one hand side
be event oriented
interpretation tendencies in general,
as we have already seen in the quote
from the old for example also.
So there must be
we must essentially foster
the development of this event predictive,
stable and compact, latent states
this what seems
what our brain seems to do.
And it.
Seems to develop these event states
in terms of attempting to characterize
starting conditions, contextual
conditions and in conditions of events.
So contextual conditions
means like when can invent unfold
and what is happening
typically why an event unfolds.
The starting condition means
when can this an event start out?
So I can reach only for an object
when it's in reach.
So for example now
and the ending condition.
So essentially. When an event.
And so again reaching
event ends is typically when I grasp
an object for example
an appears that there is event
predictive biases is inductive
bias has to segment
our stream of information
into this events
and two very important
ones are probably signals of surprise
because usually when I don't
have a good event or when I don't know
exactly how an event unfolds,
I get to really first
better to, for example,
extend my hands, reach for things
and so forth, but then may touch them.
I fail to grasp and properly and
they fall down and this is surprising.
And then I get.
Surprise signals which over time
become non surprising any more
because I know that
when I reach for the object
then to begin to grasp and forward
and then prepare
for the grasp, and then. I
manage.
The whole sequence without the surprises.
And the other one
is this latent signals of stability
because
and this also relates to causality.
In a sense,
because our I mean, our environment of a.
World is a three dimensional space time
continuum, essentially.
And forces
or causal interactions can only unfold
when two entities
can exchange these forces.
And this is typically,
in the physical world, only possible
when they come in contact with each other
via Zoom.
And we we can exchange information
over this long range.
Long range means, but also in the sense
we are in contact right now.
Right by.
This tool, by this digital device,
essentially, and the Internet.
That.
Enables us to. Now.
Establish virtual rooms.
That's why a zoom room, for example,
is also called a Zoom room.
Yeah, because it's a virtual room
where we are together, not physically,
but information wise.
We can exchange information
and thoughts and ideas and so forth.
And that's essentially very similar
to being in the real room that typically
similar things. Are. Mainly unfolding.
And so this is the event predictive
biases that make us structure our.
Environment and our our.
Thoughts and our general
predictive models in this event,
composition and manner,
and the other one is,
of course, the importance of curiosity
in homeostasis to make sure that we on
the one hand side, essentially, I mean,
our brain has does not have the capacity.
Our brain has some phenomenal capacity
for sure, but certainly doesn't
have the capacity to learn everything
in all its detail about it.
Yeah. I mean it's totally impossible.
I mean, otherwise we would need
to learn down to quantum mechanics how.
Everything unfolds the whole time. Right?
So this is.
This. Is absolute impractical.
So of course, we need to develop models
that we believe, so to say,
are best suited for our needs right?
So while we build.
Our models
and why we pursue active inference,
as you're already seen in the active
inference equation, right, there
is this important component
that essentially tries to minimize
the divergence between desired
perceptions and actual perceptions.
Right.
And this is essentially maintaining
internal homeostasis of Friston
would argue
also that it's this perception, right?
It's not necessarily
only about the outside environment,
but it's also the perception
of your own body. Right.
So if you desperately hungry
or starving or whatever.
Right, then of course you do everything
to prevent this from happening.
Hopefully it doesn't get to this.
And and curiosity
meanwhile, of course, drives
our curious minds.
Our knowledge gain experience.
But also this knowledge
gained experience is partially embodied.
So also our sensory system
kind of signals to us
what is probably interesting for us.
And it's going hand in hand
with the homeostasis component.
We build models mainly about the stuff
that really interests us
and that we believe is important to us
in our which cultural social world.
Of course, this can be very awkward,
very cool,
artistic things and so forth,
but nonetheless, right.
It is still in the human run important.
But when we do
and we try to implement this now. In.
Artificial neural network structures.
I want to. Show you a couple of
brief glimpses, at least at
what we have done in my group
over the last couple of years.
The first that I want to show
you is a derivative of this rocket
ball system where we now.
Have.
Again, similar
continue a network structure,
but we have to enhance the system now,
not only processing sensory
and motor information
predicting sensory consequences
as in the rocket ball thing.
And that mighty.
Joint arm that you saw before,
but also. We.
Allow it
to give a contextual input stage,
which is essentially like an event stage
that develops.
The. Ability to distinguish
between different vehicles
that the system is currently controlling.
Notice recall that the system
as a sensory input get gets x, y
positions of the vehicle and motor.
Commands are.
These two or four thrust motors.
So it
doesn't see which vehicle it's
currently controlling.
It only sees its position.
And so in order to distinguish
the different vehicles, it
either needs to enhance its latent
state is in the long, short term memory
structure of the Cartoon Network
structure, or it needs to contextualize
a latent latent inductive bias
essentially here.
And by training this,
lo and behold, can do this.
Now, this is a trained. Model and it can.
Learn to control this for three vehicles
that have different inertia
and gravity properties. And
and also.
Thrust different thrust motors than does
so thus this now essentially.
Buy on the.
One hand side continuously doing this
active inference with a line
that you see again the thought projecting
where it will be in the future,
but also it retrospectively
continuously adapts its internal event
estimate of which vehicle it's
currently controlling
or not really of which vehicle
is currently controlling.
What's rather
what's the best contextual state.
That allows.
Me to predict the current sensorimotor
dynamics in the best way.
And it does this rather well.
Lo and behold,
if you plot the internal state,
this contextual state, that emerges
that's not trained or in a sense
like super traits are not trained in
a supervised way, but it's trained via.
An active.
Inference process, essentially.
So it emerges like a distinction
between the three different vehicles
by just simply optimizing
this forward model of the dynamics
of the different mix
of the three vehicles
and having the inductive bias
that's important here too, to succeed
essentially that the vehicles
do not switch all the time,
but they are stable for a while,
like about 50 steps or something.
And then they randomly switch
at a certain point in.
Time and and.
The inductive phases
that this contextual vector that's hidden
here, essentially there's a stable vector
that only adapts itself
much slower than the internal dynamics
of the actual recurrent neural network.
And then during training
such these structures typically merge
distinguishing the three vehicles
and you can even train this to transport
objects then that somewhat polarizations
are possible are necessary to do so.
But admittedly,
these these structures do emerge,
but not very robustly.
And the structure of this latent state
is still typically rather fuzzy.
So over the last two years,
we essentially have produced
a couple of other neural networks
that really try. To.
Work on this compression and the suitable
compression of this latent states.
Further,
we have
done this with various gating networks
originally first to providing
surprise signals or essentially surprise
when the switch occurs
and we just give it a switch
occurrence signal.
That was last year, essentially
where we develop nice latent codes
for predicting some abstract functions,
for example, in distinguishing
between them, even seeing
some similarities between them.
But then.
This here.
At the Cox.
II meeting, we. Have.
Done this again.
So we see
we have this event anticipation module.
This is a
still rather simple neural network.
Then we have an event switching module
that's a gated recurrent unit
network here that allows the next
anticipation of the next event code
or the passing of the next event code
into the lower level
event processing structure
that is actually processing the sensory
information only at certain points
in time when this event boundary
anticipation network actually
activates a switch and this event bound
anticipation network learns
to activate the switch by a particular,
suitably
designed inductive learning biases.
So the first inductive based essentially
design of the model that you develop
essentially an event processing module.
That is.
Contextualized by the belief of which
what's the current most suitable
event code?
So what's the event that's unfolding?
And then event bound anticipation module
that essentially switches between events
just in time and lo and behold,
this system actually Jerry does learn
to switch when the information is there
that it can know
when the event switches.
That it learns an optimal model.
About the switches.
And if you have, for example,
in this case we use like well not encoded
symbolic sequences and different sequence
processing out of matter basically.
Then the.
System developed distinct event codes
for the three types. Of.
Dynamics, for example.
And interestingly, because you see.
Two P, one to the event,
one to program, one essentially to.
Switch and b b to switches
between B and C and three.
The problem is three switches
between APC.
V. APC V.
So it's a kind of a combination.
Of problem one and. Problem two.
And so lo
and behold, the P three code essentially
is between the P one code
and the P two code in all the cases,
although of course, two different
initialization
of the three different networks, they
of course develop different latent codes.
But they still kind of
and. Imply
the underlying structure of the events
and the similarity between events.
But maybe the most advanced network
is the one here again from Chris
together
trying to work with scale matches here.
This paper now that essentially
also has a very similar structure,
you have a hidden latent state
that's in the previous previous code
that's essentially.
In. This network that's it's this code
that is passed down through here
and this hidden latent code
is maintained over time
and is just controlled
or can be adjusted by a gate.
It's a much bigger cascade
that opens only very selectively.
And this gate. Is.
Is designed
such that there is a lost function.
That.
Punishes gate openings.
So the system really doesn't
really want to open its gate.
But if it's really helpful. To.
Lower the prediction error on the side,
it does.
So it's also open the gate
and thus changes context
with this obvious recommendation system
or this event.
Coding system
that has the.
Next event code ready to switch to it
just in.
Time, and then combines this
to predict the next consequences.
So again, sense, remote event,
predictive model essentially.
And this.
System is now quite ready to
to process state of the art
challenges here not only toy problems
as in the admittedly in the last
and the two other systems.
So for example
there's a billiard ball scenario
which is a kind of a benchmark machine
learning community.
Where.
Our system with suitable parameterization
decreases.
The mean squared error much.
More than standard Alice tem accrual
or standard recurrent neural networks.
And particularly
when you have a testing scenario.
That.
Differs
a little bit from the training scene.
And what's even more important maybe
or more interesting in this scenario
is that the matching to this illustration
here, you see essentially.
That the.
Length and state of the
our system called gate lord.
Essentially,
you can really
see that there is a particular dynamic
unfolding right now.
So first. Of all.
Those in a certain direction, after
the first interaction with the boundary,
the legend stage perfectly switches
to one stable new state.
And then this second bounce and again
it switches to a new state.
So that's.
Very powerful.
A little bit hand-waving due to time
can explain
all of the all of the components here.
But do you see a really nice
generalization behavior?
For example, when you train
only this fetch and pick and place.
Task in.
In situations
where the group object contact
always occurs at time point five.
And. In generalization,
the contact also occurs at other time
points.
Immediately,
the ALICE term and crew networks
get much worse
in their predictive accuracy.
Okay, so it's to generalize this
to this other scenarios
and there are a couple of.
Other also.
Combinations with reinforcement
learning systems.
So actually we took our
the question took that gate lot module
essentially this model learning module
and combined it
with state of the art reinforcement
learning systems.
And as a result
we could beat, learn faster,
be more simple, efficient essentially
and be partially more accurate.
Than the. State of the art reinforcement.
Learn us in the couple of this
many great world tasks.
For example.
So really important. To.
Induce the right inductive
learning biases.
These essentially improve
the late and state codes that
much more systematically seem to develop.
Really.
Kind of in explaining called like
explaining the causality in in
with a latent code about what's
really going on in the environment,
such as where
the sheep, for example, is or.
Where the call.
Position will be if, if the system
remembers where the key is on one side
and so forth.
So particularly a very suited
also for partially observable
Markov decision process problems.
So where you need to maintain longer
term.
Memory.
Of particular events
happened in particular environments.
Okay, so that's a second part
of the neural networks.
And if you still have
a couple of minutes. I.
Try to
put you through the last component
into that.
I wanted to show you. That. Event.
This event, predictive structures
can be very closely related to language.
And that.
I find most exciting because this might.
And in fact I'm really.
Close to language gap and really clear
around language in our sensorimotor
experience is by this tendency
to develop event predictive structures
that are then very simple,
very easily linked to the language
that each of us experiences
while we grow up.
Let me show. You.
What I mean by this event.
Predictive structures
in terms of a language domain.
Let's take this this example of of a ball
that rolled on the table
because it was cricket.
For example, now.
And so if.
You read the sentence, actually,
it was crooked.
Yeah. You,
you might say or the ball was crooked.
That's why I wrote down
and that's probably was the table.
So so
how come we we are able to make sense
of the sentence with it's
particularly being think of us ambiguous
being referential ambiguity here
being able to.
Be. Be bound to the subject
or the object essentially.
And so what I mean,
what happens when we read such a sentence
is essentially that while we process and
and so we read the ball
and it created create
probably a kind of a predictive
and coding structure of the ball
so the ball can roll and bounce.
And it.
It gets repelled when it hit something
and it has some particular size
and possibly
we also imagine some kind of particular.
Ball.
Like a soccer ball or something
depending on what are usually
not very visual
person. So I don't usually.
Imagine that an actual ball.
And then I then read roll down.
So the rolling is much more active
than the falling at this point
and I imagine the ball essentially
rolling somewhere.
Somehow and then.
This somewhere
somehow is specified. That's the table.
So it rolls down the table.
So apparently.
It's.
There's a table and there's a tabletop
so it's probably
on the surface of the table
that rolling event unfolds.
And so I put this together
and I have this rolling down,
as we've seen before, the baby
expecting the rolling in, the falling,
if Now this event structure
right of a ball rolling down,
meaning like it rolled
first on the surface
and then it probably dropped down
somewhere.
That's rolling down the table.
And now we read
because it was crooked essentially.
And this essentially implies that the
course due to the because situation right
that essentially was the second
part of the sentence was not true or like
this is explaining part of the sentence
that because part right
so was it not crooked
then the rolling event
would not not take place this essentially
counter factual reasoning.
Right
so so can it be that the ball is crooked
and that's it roll down the table
and that's
if the boy would have some sort
of crooked dent or whatever, it's most
likely has not rolled down the table.
So that seems to be not so plausible.
So but kind of.
Tilted crooked
table seems to be much more plausible.
So most likely it was the table
that was assigned with a pronoun, right.
So we can we have essentially analyzed
the whole event with its causality in.
It by.
Imagining the words that we read
and the sentence structure
that we perceive as grammar. And.
Generating in imagination
of what we perceive.
And then actually we have
this year was together this question
Stegeman Phillips Pfaff published a paper
on the so-called learner architecture,
which essentially learns
about an environment
in event predictive structure.
It is trained. Informed.
How. To.
Link the individual
event components
that it has learned out of its
observing in environment,
with the language process, the system.
And then it can in fact do just what
I have illustrated.
It can disambiguate ambiguous sentences
by creating
concrete
imaginations of an a state of affair.
So, for example, we have here this.
This scenario.
Unfortunately looks like are viruses
here.
This has nothing to do with Corona.
So sorry about it.
It was created before
the whole damn pandemic.
But nonetheless, what's important
is that these creatures
here pushed on stuff
from these platforms.
And our learner.
System analyzes
these things and essentially creates
even predictive structures out of it.
And so then after it has learned this,
it can essentially generate
sentence interpretation.
So after training, essentially
you can create give it a sentence such as
the green virus rests on the platform
and it moves to the box after it falls.
So rather complex sentence
and what the system then is doing,
it can create itself out of the entities
that. Are.
Uttered like a green virus, a platform
and box,
which has been decided to be green here.
So that's randomly chosen
then maybe it's not specified.
It's a range.
Is these three objects in such a way
such that it can imagine
an event sequence
unfolding in this constellation
to make the sentence true.
So you can see this in this video here.
So essentially the system learned
to generate this constellation of the C
and the virus.
Lo and behold, falls
on the platform, actually,
and then it rests on the platform
for a little while,
and then it moves to the box
after it has fallen the platform.
So this is the interpretation of
the sentence that the system has created.
And I think it's a nice illustration
hopefully for you also convincing
illustration
that this event structures, sentences
addressing event structures.
Can be.
What we make of it.
What meaning?
Making sense of a sentence is essentially
something like this is the internal
creation of a consistent event
or event progression.
That.
Fits to the described tendency
to disambiguate, of course, certain.
Temporal and and.
Referential and so forth, ambiguities
that might be inherent
in the sentence and grammatical structure
that is provided.
We have also just recently shown that
this event predictive
inference structure also nicely
fits to the rational speech model.
Actually, for that matter.
And one.
Can nicely model.
Learning.
About the preferences of others.
This essentially
this example in this study
goes with actual behavior experiments
done on my work years.
So for example,
you can imagine when you have a scene
like this in this admittedly
very abstract entities here.
And so for example, have the scenario
and Maria wants to signal
an object to the following scene
in the following scene to Samantha.
So Maria Maria says read,
please take a read one essentially.
And Samantha chooses the angel object
such as she takes
the red cloud here, red stripe cloud.
Then you can possibly infer something
about preferences.
Low and behold, she might like,
for example, clouds more than circles.
But you don't know anything
about squares because it was no option
to choose from squares.
And you can also, by the active
inference, formalism
within this formalism, actually, you can
then also do it the other way around.
And you want to, for example,
possibly learn about
Elizabeth as preferences.
And therefore only in this scenario
can give options to choose among objects.
So for example, if you want to.
Learn.
About if the say if the person prefers
clouds or circles,
you could for example, say,
pick one of the green ones
and then you would see
if she person takes the cloud or circle.
And then you have some hint
that the person might
prefer clouds or circles, for example.
And we have monitors in this recursive
inference process very closely
related to the active inference.
Formalism use a typical kind of urgency
to look like l divergence again,
where. We.
Essentially. Compare our prior.
Knowledge of feature preferences
of our expected posterior
knowledge of future preferences
by pursuing a particular action,
that particular utterance.
And when we compare this to the actual
behavior of the human participants,
we get really good fits
and in fact could show us a.
From a from a from.
The information criterion
manner that our cognitive model fits
better.
Than than other. Competitive models.
And this leads me
to the end of my presentation now.
So just a language
really briefly in the end,
but I hope you see what I mean by that.
This is when predictive cognition
essentially and the active
inference processes
that unfold this within this event,
predictive cognitive systems
and our brains for that matter,
most likely are very compatible
to a linguistic structures.
So what I have shown you today,
and I hope you could follow me
so fine, wasn't too much
that essentially our generative mind.
Yeah.
May have may have the self-motivated
objective to act highly flexibly
and go direct and pursue epistemic
self-motivated actions in general.
This is quite clear to survive, right,
to interact with our complex floods,
to seeing that we have become this
crazy human beings with all our social
likes and dates and capability
and intelligence and so forth.
On this human cognitive level event,
predictive conceptualizations
seem to be really important
to enable us to act in a deeper, goal
directed, self-motivated manner
and to conceptualize our environment.
Thus, to be able to communicate
and interact and cooperate
with others and compete
also with each other, for that matter.
In a.
Highly more sophisticated manner
than. Any.
Other animals
can to learn such conceptualizations.
We really need
this inductive learning biases, and it's
certainly not fully figured out yet.
How this learning and.
Processing biases. Are.
Working, weakening our functioning.
But we know
one can
show clearly that this concept Jasons
are really good to enable deeper goal
directed, self-motivated planning,
reasoning, counterfactual reasoning,
filling in gaps, finding and unknowns.
Disambiguate ambiguous situations.
And pursuing yet abstract.
And concrete behaviors
on multiple levels.
And last point
was that language seemed to be mapped
really rather simplistic easily on this,
which essentially possibly might.
Explain why.
We as babies naturally.
Learn our mother tongue without much,
obviously much effort and particular.
The complexity of the grammar behind it.
Also know
no artificial intelligence side.
I would like to conclude. With that that.
The current deep learning systems
most because they don't foster
this general activity
and this conceptualization of structures,
they do not really foster event
predictive generative models
and as others have said
thus many may call. The.
More simpler architectures
that are nonetheless including systems
like transformers
and so forth, really still rather highly
computationally demanding
stochastic parrots, arguably.
And interesting
to discuss this, of course,
I believe that
if we develop more event predictive
generative systems,
then we actually foster the development
of the learning of generative models,
that is, and ideally causal models
of the actual true
causal letter that we encounter via
our sensorimotor experiences,
enabling us to generate much more robust
for costs, possible action
recommendations and explanations of why
we would recommend particular things
or forecast particular things.
Because we essentially are designed
to learn about the causes.
That. Lead us to predict certain things.
So we can also of course
talk about the causes.
And in my opinion, these systems may
then indeed use strongly
AI or artificial general intelligence
where self-motivated
learning will be inevitable,
part of such systems.
And. Self-Motivated learning.
And so that behavior
thus will be part of these systems.
And so.
I think it's.
We should be aware
that there is no reason.
I see no reason.
Research on human cognition
and it's functionally
no reason
why an artificial system should not reach
such intelligence level.
And so, as others also have pointed out,
I want to conclude with a.
With.
A word of caution, essentially,
and a word of awareness that
if these systems come into being
come into existence, yes,
we need to make very much sure
that we don't design
just for profit or for.
Some.
Individual personal interests.
But we better put a good person purpose
into these systems.
And it's a good idea
to think about this now more so.
This concludes my talk.
Thank you so much for attention.
Parts of this general motivation
and background you can find in my.
Book from.
20 1617.
How. The mind comes into being.
And I.
Some funding from the Humboldt
Foundation and.
Mainly and.
Thank you for my team
actually to produce much of this work.
I don't have a team slide here.
And but thank you for your.
Attention as well.
Awesome presentation.
Thank you very much. Thank you.
Maybe you can unshared
and we can have a little discussion.
Mm hmm.
Definitely.
Well, tons of very interesting ideas.
Anyone can write a question in the chat.
But let me just start
with a introductory question.
How did you come to be working
with active models?
What were you working on before?
Was it a system specific or question
specific path that led you to integrate
these novel components
into active inference?
Yes, thanks.
I just little bit confused
because it's this camera.
No name. Okay. Um,
but let me.
Actually turn. To the screen then.
Yes. Well,
I have studied all my research career,
essentially started to study
anticipatory behavior
from the very early on during
diploma, a bachelor's degree studies
essentially coming into contact
with a psychologist
in which spoke Joachim Hoffmann's
group on anticipatory behavior control.
And I think in his work,
he already essentially
from the psychological perspective. Of.
Formalizes
this principle, of active inference on a
on the very crude, more in words
specified psychological level
where and I started very early
to also realize that.
That was the.
Devil's in the details.
And the.
Question is really
what are representations like what
what is the representations that
this anticipations that this predictions
actually unfold?
What What's the nature
of these representations?
And even now a days, we still see
lots of machine learning work.
Where.
Representations are given in advance
and so forth.
And or are.
Just totally done by, let's say,
the Atari games or these successes.
I mean, there
you just give the play an image and you
you kill the problem with so much data.
That it still.
Converges,
but the system is not really learning
the system activity,
the actual structure of the problem.
And but most recent advances,
of course, also from others.
For example, the
the dreamer.
Architecture or the planet architecture
from from
what's his name.
Haffner is the last name.
This course also very close
in this direction but not.
Oh designer.
Half. Yeah. Yes.
They goes in this direction,
but They don't really foster
event predictive laden codes yet
and I think.
They should.
Cool.
I have some predictions
about where you might go,
but just to sort of restate it,
you said just in your previous
answer that it was a crude
active inference in words.
And so I wanted to ask what is active
inference crudely in words?
And then what key
pieces of the formalism today
refined those words?
And then what do you see
being incorporated into the formalism
going forwards?
So what's what's active
inference, crudely speaking and words?
It's well, it's
active inference essentially formalizes.
How our.
Minds and how clever learning systems
should infer
to develop generative models
about the world and use this models
to pursue says motivated co-directed
behavior.
That's the general formalism.
And my point
today was essentially that this formalism
is overly general in a sense,
because it doesn't
specify the nature.
Of. The encoding of the predictive
coatings.
And. Evolution
as obviously shaped our minds,
such that we have particular
expectations
of this suitable of the structure
that's suitable to model the outside
environment and thus interact with this.
Environment in a.
More flexible, adaptive, directed,
socially competent manner.
And that's where the event
predictive stuff falls in.
Thank you for the answer.
Now a sequence of events
might have a narrative could be said
that connects them.
How does narrative relate to your work
here?
Is that just a bigger nesting event
or how do we connect micro-scale events,
which it's very nice
how you, you know, rolling off
the table was a clear demonstration
of that kind of an event.
How does that connect to broader
narratives?
Yeah, very good question.
Good and very interesting
is I think.
As I said in as I tried
to imply also that the events exists
on multiple
levels of granularity
and precision in an event can consist of.
Yet sup events essentially. Right.
I mean like the whole episode
of writing a letter, for example,
consists of writing individual words,
sentences, paragraphs, thoughts,
expressing individual
thought components and so forth, right?
So, so. And.
So on.
Event per say.
Can I mean you have the.
Event of your current day.
Right? And you compress this as an event.
So, so this.
So that's the beauty about it
I think also because.
An. Event.
It's not it's not
there's not only one event
unfolding in our minds.
In every.
Here and now situation,
but it's it's about these
different aspects
that have beginnings and endings, right?
Like this, like meeting here.
But my answer to your question,
my individual sentences,
my individual words,
my actual utterances that I produce,
these are all events nested
within each other.
And each of these components
is characterized by certain stability.
Situations
like the whole why we have this meeting,
the in a certain
interactive situation and this is more
or less stable during the whole meeting.
I guess, I'm the presenter here today
and so forth.
And then we have listeners
and you are the, the mediator so to say.
Right,
and this is the situation all the time.
And this table front from the beginning
of the end, from the whole situation.
Right.
But when you pose me a question,
then you focus in on this question
answering situation event
and that's one particular event
within nested within the other event.
And while I produce my train of thought,
there are also the events again
unfold, right?
So this so there's a. Lot and and.
Each of these events though
is characterized by certain stabilities.
That are.
Unfolding, such as the question
answer situation, where we focus on the
particular component of this current talk
and the current
topic of this meeting.
Awesome.
What that reminded me of was Chronos
and Kairos, two Greek word
roots for time and the chronometer
the decimal of the time.
And there's testing of chronology
like the second is within the DECA
second or the, you know, the minute,
the hour, but then Kairos, this
more semantic or action oriented
kind of timeliness also has nesting
and that can be perfectly
nothing like the example.
The letter with the sentence, the word,
etc. is funny because
it's called a letter right at the bigger
and the smaller level.
Hmm. Mm hmm.
Right.
But then also, the boundaries could be
subjective.
So not to say arbitrary,
but literally defined by the subject,
learned by the subject.
And so it seems to be no problem
to have machine learning systems
that can nest Chronos very well.
But how do we achieve an adequate nested,
action
oriented representation?
Any thoughts
or ask a question from a chat?
I think the
that's a very important part
and that's also the beauty.
I think about the event structures,
right?
That essentially it's
not it's always subjective
because it's the stability that
each of us perceives that makes an event.
Become an event now.
And I mean,
because our world for us is all the same.
We are very similar
in this event structures.
But nonetheless, of course,
the events are very
individually
unfolding in each of our minds.
And they are.
Characterized by this stability
and systematize properties
that each event has.
And the nice thing about it as well
is that
the partitioning and segmentation
is extremely flexible, right?
I mean, you can
it doesn't depend on time.
In order to.
Implement
this in machine learning systems,
you need to have a system
that can flexibly.
Maintain.
Particular latent states
over extended periods of time
and systematically change them
when the time is ripe.
So to say, and this is what we have done
with the eight
lot system
that I have showed the towards the end,
which is going to be published
in December.
Very Cool.
So I'll ask a question from the chat.
So Dean has asked
entertaining counterfactuals is time
distributing
and time provides
the twist like a mobius strip.
So if we include dire chronic continuity
with events, episodic, partitioned,
do we break free
from training
a classical
a classical dean phrasing to be sure,
which I just read literally,
rather than choose to interpret, but.
Maybe
you can help me with in the rotation.
But I would say the.
The kind of fictional component
was the problem that the counterfactual
is, is time demanding or consuming
or mentally challenging essentially to
because time is on the issue.
And so I need to be so I cannot do
counterfactual reasonings on the fly.
And that's certainly true. We have
useful typically in our best explanation
very quickly and habitually.
And only when we.
Really realize.
Errors we fall into.
Counterfactuals.
I usually give the example
with a cricket ball.
I actually usually I give
a simple example which is not dynamic.
Like the ball fits into a suitcase
because it is large, for example.
So the ball fits into the suitcase
because it is large.
So it is a suitcase
that is large and not the ball. And.
And that is kind of also. A.
Typical garden course.
Effect in language.
Linguistics where you fall
into the best interpretation.
The pronoun it.
Usually fits with the subject.
And so.
Your best hypothesis
to bind it to a subject.
You read on.
And then you get to the final sentence
and then you try to imagine
why does the ball fit in the suitcase?
And then essentially.
You. Realize
you have to revise your model.
And that's
kind of the kind of factual part
that only happens, I think, when there is
surprise or other reasons
to really pursue
this additional cognitive effort.
Great answer.
Let me see if there's a link
to what Dean suggested
and the stochastic parrot notion.
So if we think about a stochastic seed,
preferring seed, rewarding parrot,
it's like there's some maize in the seed
could be on either side.
And so it's rewarded
when it's discovering that, it's
strengthening that, and then it switches
and then it just stochastic leaf
sometimes investigates the other branch
and then reinforces that.
Now that's all time bound.
If we think about the
event as the context,
then the counterfactual
the continued possibility
of imagining a counterfactual
is kind of what allows the rapid
moving from the training
on the side that it has been on.
And in one step with one gate opening,
we can counterfactual,
we enter into a different context.
And then he adds, it's bi directional
and the not present is that.
Now let me restart this literally,
he says.
The not present is now plus then
and then plus now.
This is our ability, both episodic
and dire, chronic continuity.
That is the
what if the mind can work out. Yes.
And that's that's
that's the beautiful part, right?
I mean, our mind can essentially
by this gate openings create
a switch between alternative events
or event sub
event components switched entity property
switch other aspects of it.
And and and.
It not needs to do
so it's not only doing this
by randomly switching these things
because it usually switches them
very systematically in a meaningful
manner that actually the consequence
of an event actually changes as well.
Right.
Because you usually do what if questions
that actually change to further.
Event progression.
And you can do this.
Mentally really well and I think the.
This essentially. Can.
Could be done and should be further
explored with such gating mechanisms,
really core component for future research
think to really show that such systems
not only are able to explain events,
but can also really reason
in terms of counterfactual madness,
then saying, well,
if I switch, if this property
would have been different, then actually
the other thing would have not happened.
This is actually also really important
to assign blame, for example, to people.
Would.
What you not have shot the ball
or something like this and.
That's.
That's also very socially.
Relevant lo and behold there.
As well as designing education
and thinking about when are we trying to
when are we fine tuning
but not opening or changing a gate?
And then it made me think about that
equation which you did an awesome job
to walk through and showed read it
because like sensory motor inputs
the the equation is a linear string,
but then we can engage
in this counterfactual.
What if the inference on observables
weren't conditioned on policy
and actually to have competency with
those equations
is to know a little bit
about counterfactuals.
And then on the cutting edge
you're drawing from other fields
and you're asking looking at pazuello
and Friston at all 2015
and then asking, well,
what if this formalism included
another event based
cognitive framework
that was not previously connected?
So it's like the learning trajectory
for those of us
who are learning the equations includes
the counterfactuals and the gate opening,
and then research is just kind of
going one step further.
And so just made me wonder
about how we design education
to accommodate this kind of gate
opening and counterfactual space.
How we accommodate education,
the what?
What for what kind of education you mean?
Yes, what.
Which education you're referring.
To the.
Human.
Human education
for learning, active inference
or for learning another area?
Yeah, I think it's good
and interesting. If I.
Thought I would say it's it's
I think it's.
Extremely useful for sure to know
particularly also
to look at the equations and.
And analyze. Their components.
And then.
Progressively also enhance them
or selectively compact them, take
kick away the one segment or the other
and then you see exactly
what's happening. So
I guess hopefully this was educational.
How I presented it, I guess.
It's a flow of sensory inputs
and then there's some discrete.
Structures.
If you think about the individual
components in the equation
as as event components,
in the sense.
Very cool.
I have one more question
and then maybe any closing thoughts
you mentioned,
you know, the Zoom room or the
the Gizzi room, online
events, calendar events.
Do we all get invited to?
That's just very interesting
with how we're bringing our evolutionary
and our ecological behavioral embodiments
into, the digital space.
And so
what does it bode for online events,
thinking beyond just webinars, but like
how do we think about online events?
Because in one sense,
you're very local to me.
You're in my headphones
giving me the sensory flow,
but you're on a different continent.
And so where do you think or what
theoretical questions
or applied questions does it
raise to think about online events,
which are a novel affordances
from an evolutionary perspective?
I mean, I think for the one for the one
good of it,
they have shown us
that we don't need to fly as much around
the globe
as we have done before the pandemic,
which is probably
a really good thing for our planet.
And we should acknowledge this.
And accept. This. I think
I have the impression that
particularly older colleagues
have issues for that.
And I think it's.
It's a very good and important thing
that we should be all aware of.
That and.
Shout it out loud as I do right
now, that why. Now?
And the.
Very severe situation for our.
World and this.
Pandemic has shown us
also and even shows us now
how we humans are so easily able. To.
Neglect things or deny things
that are so obvious
that they are occurring, which.
Very scary and very.
Unfortunate for our own future.
Meanwhile, saying this,
I think it was a great opportunity to
for all of us
to acknowledge that video cards
like this work really well.
And of course, after one
and a half years of pandemic,
I guess all of you guys also. Enjoy.
Local meetings again. And.
Going out with other people.
So we also see how
social we creatures are
and what is missing in such video calls.
Which is.
Of course, the personal interaction
and really the development of
of getting a feel of how the other person
really takes us personally.
And when you can make a statement
about what's actually
happening and through life out there,
that's of course, very different.
Unfortunately,
not possible via Zoom calls.
But so I can only urge everybody that.
We should be aware that
when we fly around the world,
we better make it worthwhile.
And on to
it is only for a couple of days.
It Made me think of a trilemma fly.
We could have met in person, you know.
We could have met in Iceland
or something. Somewhere in the middle.
There is an impact in the hardware
and the bandwidth of a video call,
and that impact is very cloaked.
And then there's also machine
learning models.
And so maybe somehow I don't know
if X is the impact of a flight
is a video call 0.1 or 1,000th
or one millionth of a flight,
and making some of these
impacts that are very real clearer
so that we can design events
that are policies
that align with our preferences
to reduce our uncertainty
and to connect socially,
but also to pragmatically keep certain
ecological parameters
within a region that we can
thrive in
case. Absolutely, that would be good.
I mean, a video call it certainly
if less than a million,
I think I'm a flight,
although of course, it is significant.
But it's I mean, incomparably less.
And but.
Nonetheless, one has to be,
of course, also be aware that,
unfortunately, we are in a situation
where we really need global efforts.
So one cannot really point fingers
to individual persons
because we need global
policy changes to save our.
Own world and our future of our children.
And I have three kids. And.
I'm very concerned.
Do you have anything that you'd like
to just leave us with or.
That's a perfect closing note?
No, I don't want to leave
on the downside.
Sure.
But it's a great pleasure to
to do this with you guys.
And now we drift
a little bit to the climate.
And I'm.
I'm. Thankful
that we also can talk about this.
A little bit.
And but I hope it's I mean.
It's hopefully you also see
that it's an amazingly exciting topic.
And not only.
One inside how our human mind works.
And how.
We manage to be as intelligent,
but also as limited as we.
Are in the end.
And but meanwhile, I also I think it
has certainly I mean, this
is amazingly
developing over the last couple of years.
And yes, and.
There I guess also things go so far.
So it's important that. We.
Think about the dangerous of AI.
And unfortunately,
as we have seen this, Cambridge
Analytica is only an example of what is.
Going on right now.
In terms of.
AI driven, targeted.
Influence of our own selves and our way.
We think about stuff and our beliefs
and hopefully we will manage
also to foster this awareness of this
and thus be more ready to contact it
and find back to our.
Beautiful human social.
Abilities.
Thank you for that
excellent and uplifting note.
It was really an honor.
Martin So thanks again
for the presentation and the chat.
Really appreciate it as well.
You and any colleagues are always
welcome to
come on a live stream or to get involved
in the act and flop in any way.
So this was just a great conversation
and it was hopefully very informative for
our audience as well.
I hope so too.
Thanks for inviting me here
and thanks for running this lab.
It seems to be a really good group
and I hope we can stay in contact
over the next month. And yes.
Thank you. We will.
Okay. Take care.
See you. Bye bye.
Thank you.